توجهنا الى مدينه مريوبل لتغطيه تجمع
مسلمي مقاطعه دانيات في مسجد المدينه
الكبير المسلمون مما يقطنون مدينه دانيتك
يسافرون الى ماريوبل لاداء الصلاه في يوم
الجمعه
وللمشاركه في موائد الرحمن حيث ان مساجدهم
قريبه من مناطق النزاع في الاحياء الغربيه
من العاصمه لا تزال مدينه ماريوبل اكثر
امنا من غيرها من المدن في مقاطعه دانياتك
كونها تقع على بعد مسافه من قواعد القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تقصف مدن الموالين لروسيا
ذلك ما اتاح للمسلمين هنا اقامه طقوسهم
الدينيه في شهر رمضان الفضيل شراب
خلال اليومين الماضيين كان الافطار في
مدينه مكيفكا واليوم نفطر في ماريوبل وغدا
ان شاء الله في غورلفكا وبعده في شختار
شريحه كبيره من العاملين في قطاع البناء
هم من المسلمين ذوي الاصول الاسيويه وقد
رحلوا الى هذه المناطق للمشاركه في اعاده
اعمار المدينه
هنا اوضاع حربيه لذلك يتوجب علينا التواجد
بقرب اخوتنا في الدين من المسلمين ويجب
علينا مساعدتهم وتقديم الدعم لهم وفي
الدرجه الاولى الدعم الروحاني هنا في مسجد
ماريوبل الكبير يجتمع المسلمون الروس
لاحياء طقوسهم الدينيه على موائد الرحمن
التي قامت على انشائها ومدها الهيئه
العامه للمسلمين في مقاطعه
يقدم الطعام في شهر رمضان الفضيل لزائري
المسجد ويجتمع المسلمون هنا في وقت
الافطار على اختلاف منابتهم ومن جميع
انحاء الاقليم لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد
الاغبر ماريوبل
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات